[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24
este es un magazine informativo 100%
dedicado al continente africano mi
nombre liliana valencia aquí damos una
mirada en profundidad a los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cura de la
humanidad
se realizaron elecciones generales en
ghana el actual mandatario nana
akufo-addo intenta mantenerse en el
poder al enfrentarse al ex presidente
john badham a aquel que asuma el mando
durante los próximos cuatro años
enfrentará grandes retos en materia de
economía y también de seguridad tenemos
reportes con nuestra enviada especial
la onu logró acceso para brindar
alimentos a los casi 100.000 refugiados
eritreos que permanecen en la región
etíope del tigre en medio del conflicto
por medio de un acuerdo con el gobierno
de etiopía será posible brindar
asistencia a esta población
y se desarrolla en la ciudad española de
tarifa la decimoséptima edición del
festival de cine africano donde
directores y actores emergentes de
diferentes países muestran lo mejor de
sus creaciones
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días y empezamos en
ghana porque la novena economía de
áfrica con un producto interno bruto
equivalente al de panamá y la población
de 29.5 millones de personas realizó
elecciones generales el favorito para
ganar la contienda será actual
presidente nana akufo addo considerado
como un ejemplo por sus logros
democráticos y su robusto crecimiento
este país anglófono edáfica occidentales
sigue siendo económicamente frágil y
quien asuma el mando en 2021 enfrenta
las grandes retos según informa nuestra
enviada especial mariana con
uno de los grandes retos que enfrentará
el nuevo gobierno es dar un giro a la
economía del país y especialmente
encontrar una solución para la creación
de empleo entre los jóvenes a 26 años en
lo cual tiene una maestría en diseño y
arte gráfico desde hace tres años
trabaja como un mototaxi un trabajo
prohibido en el país cuando terminas la
escuela no tienes trabajo lo que intento
decir es que si el gobierno puede
hacerlo estaría bien
sin ver su futuro y todo el trabajo de
lo cual espera la legalización de los
mototaxis
tal vez el gobierno podría ayudarnos
legalizando nuestro trabajo
asegúrate de que todos tengan su
licencia a su seguro para trabajar
en resumen todo en orden a otros colegas
de enteros tistas y no esperan nada del
gobierno
lo que hacemos es sobrevivir porque si
no tienes nada nadie te va a dar nada
de fábrica es serio en esto es un lugar
donde tenemos un montón de gobiernos que
vienen y dicen auto de salud para esto
haré eso no cumplen sus promesas sólo
unos pocos lo hacen poco yo de la
función de a promise
gyan ghana el número de pobres apenas ha
disminuido en el último decenio en
prometió una cuarta parte de la
población sigue viviendo por debajo del
umbral de pobreza en el futuro el
gobierno debe embestir en la
distribución de la riqueza
previamente hablamos con nuestra enviada
especial a accra la capital de ghana
marian con el que nos contó cómo
transcurrió esta jornada electoral
es oficial el presidente actual nana
akufo-addo está comenzando un segundo
último mandato presidencial según las
cifras temporales de la comisión
electoral el engaño estas elecciones
presidenciales con un poco más de 52 por
ciento de los votos esta victoria no es
una sorpresa en realidad porque las
encuestas lo mostraron como el gran
ganador de estas elecciones tampoco es
sin sorpresa que el partido de la
oposición que quedó en segundo lugar con
más de 47 por ciento de los votos
refutar a los resultados y pide un
recuento de los votos en algunas
regiones como recordar yo este lunes
poco más de 17 millones de ghaneses
fueron invitados a votar por su futuro
presidente de la república y sus
senadores aunque todos salían bien la
policía indicó que las violencias
causaron la muerte de cinco personas y
que 17 resultaron heridas
las violencias estarían el lunes día de
la votación y el martes mientras el
recuerdo de los votos con
en diferentes partes del país hablamos
ahora del conflicto en etiopía porque
tras haber pedido acceso para poder
brindar ayuda a los cerca de 100.000
refugiados eritreos que permanecen en la
región del tigre en medio del conflicto
la onu logró firmar un acuerdo con el
gobierno etíope gracias al cual será
posible la entrega de suministros y
atención médica a dicha población veamos
el informe
una anhelada luz se encendió para los
refugiados en el tigre en medio de los
enfrentamientos que los habían dejado
sin asistencia humanitaria con la firma
de un acuerdo entre el gobierno de
etiopía y la onu las organizaciones
sociales que trabajan en esta región
podrán volver al terreno un día antes de
que se produjera la firma del acuerdo el
portavoz del alto comisionado de la onu
para los refugiados ya había alertado
sobre las repercusiones del bloqueo a la
asistencia de esta cerca de 96 mil
personas que en su mayoría llegaron allí
huyendo de la violencia
los campamentos se quedarán sin
alimentos lo que hará que el hambre y la
desnutrición sean un peligro real una
advertencia que venimos emitiendo desde
que comenzó el conflicto hace casi un
mes
también estamos alarmados por los
informes no confirmados de ataques
secuestros y reclutamiento forzoso en
los campos de refugiados
desde hace más de cuatro semanas el
ingreso de los trabajadores sociales
permanecía prohibido en esta región en
guerra en la que habitan más de 5
millones de personas lo que equivale al
5 por ciento de la población de etiopía
a pesar de que el conflicto inició el 4
de noviembre las tensiones en el tigre
venían incrementándose desde hacía
varios meses y su estallido ensombreció
el panorama de los refugiados quienes
quedaron prácticamente aislados y a
merced de las ofensivas según cálculos
de la onu sólo en los últimos días más
de 5000 refugiados huyeron al este de
sudán se espera que con la entrada en
vigor del acuerdo no sólo esta población
vulnerable recupere el acceso a ayudas
alimentarias y médicas sino también que
se adelante una misión de apoyo y la
vecina región de afar ya comenzó la
decimoséptima muestra del cine africano
de la ciudad española de tarifa que se
celebra anualmente para promover el
talento africano del séptimo arte en
esta edición compiten seis proyecciones
de ficción y tres documentales de países
como sudáfrica con la película buda in
africa que pone de manifiesto la
creciente influencia de china en el
continente afro o el título this is not
a burián y esa resurrección de lesotho
que narra la historia de una viuda de 80
años que prepara su entierro a la espera
de su muerte también participa en
proyecciones de otros países como túnez
argelia senegal y sudán marruecos
burkina faso y la república democrática
del congo desde hace varios años de
manera simultánea este festival se
realiza también en la ciudad marroquí de
tánger estas dos ciudades están
separadas por sólo 14 kilómetros de
distancia y el objetivo es promover la
unión entre áfrica y europa de las dos
ciudades más cercanas entre ambos
continentes este año el festival de cine
tarifa y tánger realizó una parte de su
agenda de manera presencial y otra de
manera virtual debido a la pandemia de
kobe de 1930 hablamos con la periodista
letizia nguema bekele que nos contó
detalles de esta iniciativa
debido a las condiciones de la pandemia
del 19 esta adicción está siendo
totalmente distinta ya que se está
celebrando en formato mixto combinando
proyecciones presenciales y online que
se pueden ver a través de la plataforma
digital firming de igual modo tampoco se
han podido invitar a los cineastas a
viajar a españa por motivos de seguridad
este festival aborda temas como el
reclutamiento de niños el terrorismo y
también el tráfico de mercancías y como
novedad también se estrena el
cortometraje zombies de la artista belga
con goles balón
vamos ahora a colombia porque a pesar de
que en este país vive la tercera
población afro más grande del continente
la lucha por el reconocimiento tanto
cultural como estadístico sigue siendo
uno de sus principales retos
organizaciones de derechos humanos
calcula que en el país viven entre 10 y
12 millones de afrodescendientes que
representarían un 26 por ciento de la
población sin embargo la falta a otro
reconocimiento y la necesidad de
implementar ascensos georreferenciados y
con autoconcepto no han permitido que
las estadísticas oficiales reflejen el
número real de ciudadanos negros la
cifra oficial según el departamento
nacional de estadística pasó del 10 por
ciento en 2005 al 7 por ciento en 2018
razón por la cual líderes
afrocolombianos denuncian genocidio
estadístico que podría afectar la
creación e implementación de políticas
públicas para esta población y acaban de
interponer una demanda reclamando la
corrección de dichas estadísticas sobre
el tema hablamos previamente con daniel
gómez integrante fundador de ilex acción
jurídica y esto fue lo que nos dijo
la razón por la cual interpusimos esta
acción de tutela tiene que ver con los
resultados del censo nacional de
población y vivienda que se efectúe en
el 2018 en los resultados del censo
encontramos que cuando se comparan con
los resultados del último censo que se
había efectuado en el año 2005 una
disminución muy significativa del número
de personas que fueron contabilizadas
como afrodescendientes mientras que en
el año 2005 aproximadamente 4 millones
300 mil personas fueron registradas como
afrodescendientes en las estadísticas
del censo en el año 2018 ese número
disminuyó a un poco menos de tres
millones de personas resolver ese
problema de invisibilidad estadística es
importante porque significa también
corregir una injusticia histórica que ha
ocurrido con la población
afrodescendiente tanto en colombia como
en otros países de américa latina que ha
sido históricamente invisibilizada en
las estadísticas bien no está bien
digamos los instrumentos de recolección
de información estatales ha sido una
constante histórica en muchos países de
la región incluyendo colombia y es hora
de corregirlo
entonces para poder garantizar los
derechos restablecer los derechos de la
población afrocolombiana necesitamos que
se corrijan esos datos del censo que de
verdad tengamos información confiable
veraz y completa sobre este grupo
poblacional y es por eso que
interpusimos la acción de tutela y
justamente finalizamos como sea que nos
llegan desde el caribe colombiano donde
la artista cartagenero kevin flores
tiene un homenaje a áfrica y a su
herencia en este país con la canción
titulada palenquera
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y caseros
a mí que vengo él
en el palenque
a mi contrato
hay palentina
cambiaste en mi vida mami con toda tu
alegría
mi único amor
para mí
fábrica para mi corazón de la cama
ay
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el videoclip fue grabado en el barrio
getsemaní de cartagena característico
por ser el barrio de los afro durante la
colonia y en san basilio de palenque el
primer polo libre del continente
americano con esta buena música
finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días y los invitamos a continuar
con más nuestra página web www punto
clave en ti cuatro puntos nos vemos más
adelante con más informaciones de
américa latina y del mundo que esté con
nosotros
de las buenas se emprenderá las bateas
[Música]
l
con la buena siempre
s
siempre
pero la pieza en palencia
el primer pueblo libre
[Música]